last ramadan we managed to raise five
hundred thousand half a million meals
for people around the globe this year
we're doing exactly the same by raising
half a million meals for people in
afghanistan yemen somalia pakistan syria
and the list goes on please donate
whether you can may allah bless you guys
brothers and sisters he's telling me i
used to struggle reading the quran daily
before you instructed instructed me to
download this app and now he's regularly
reading you can go into the description
box click the link for ios and android
and build your habit with the quran
right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
before i start i want you guys to watch
these clips and after you watch these
clips i want to come back and learn some
very very key lessons inshallah let's go
[Music]
so i came across a video on vice it was
a documentary and in this documentary it
showed
in indonesia and there is a group of
people who are transvestites so
basically uh they are transsexual male
to female or female to male and
basically they have formed for their
self a specific
house where they want to get close to
islam and the quran now to me when i
look at this sometimes what happens is
we see both as a contradiction or an
oxymoron how could you be a transsexual
muslim or gay muslim or for example i
want to read the quran i find this so
troubling now yes we know islam is very
clear on certain matters you know when
it comes to you know one identifying the
self as opposite gender et cetera at the
time of the prophet peace be upon him
there were these individuals who were
born with two genitalia um and you know
the scholars say that the active
genitalia is the one that is determines
which if you're a male or female we're
not talking about that we are talking
about people who just you know uh have a
a you know they're they're born as a as
a man biologically and they want to be a
woman or vice versa but the point is
this does that mean we deprive these
people does this mean that we shun these
people does this mean that we insult
these people i say no you know and the
reason i say no is because islam is very
very clear on the matters that shirk
is the main things that we cannot accept
in the religion and it takes one at the
fold of islam however a person who has
an inclination to homosexuality an
inclination to want them to be the
opposite gender
or whatever the inclination it might be
i do not believe
that it is right for us to shun them
like you know there was the man who came
and said oh mr allah makes xena
permissible for man this is a major sin
and this is this is this is one you know
i cannot obviously decide if if that is
worse than somebody transgender or
dressed up as a woman you know
committing sinner has
a hard punishment you know uh very
severe if you're married and very very
still if you're single as well um so i
don't know if that's him as someone
cross-dressing et cetera identifying
those opposite gender the point is this
that the man came and said makes xena
permissible to the messenger of god the
prophet says
they say get out of here how dare you
i'm the prophet of god
no he sat him down he said
would you like that for your sister
he said by allah i would never want that
for my sister. he said would you like
that for your mother he said by allah i
would never want it for my mother what
about your auntie i would not want it
for my auntie he made him reflect
he didn't shun him the point i'm trying
to make is this
if this transgender woman whatever it
may be he is someone that has memorized
the quran or whatever it may be
and these individuals are gathering
there etc
we know there are things that are not
permissible etc you know like we know
there was a companion of the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him who used to
drink alcohol but and he was used to get
the
punishment in public
but when somebody insulted him when um
said to him
may allah curse you the master allah
stopped him he said don't say that
he loves indeed he loves allah and his
messenger and he took in uh
and he was in the battle of uhud and the
battle of brother and a few other places
what we're trying to see is that
sometimes there are certain things allah
tests us with it can be our children put
yourself in those shoes
instead of shunning them it's important
for us to bring them closer if they are
going and spending time together
reciting the quran and memorizing the
quran yeah why should we stop that and
like in this documentary it said that
for example there are some of them that
feel that they can't even be a muslim
this is wrong
we need islam for them they should be a
muslim they should practice no matter
what sin they're committing they should
practice yes what they're doing might
not be permissible is not permissible in
islam this does not mean we totally cut
them off of any good
no
we try to bring them back to allah and
make them have that connection praying
their salah quran quran
have quran in your life whoever you are
whatever wherever you are have a quran
in your life
so i wanted to share that with you guys
because i found it very very sad you
know that people shun them etc yes we
can advise yes we can tell them it's
wrong whatever it may be etc but if they
are not changing their ways at least
let's not deprive them of the religion
and tell them oh how could you be a
muslim this is i think this is a sin i
mean this is it if you push them away
from islam it can be it can be a major
sin
so let's be very careful brothers and
sisters that's what i wanted to share
with you guys inshaallah may allah bless
every single one of you guys uh till
next time salaam alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatu may allah protect us and not
make us among those that look down on
others etc and then allah tests us with
those very things that we look down at
others with uh until next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh